when did you decide on documentary
filmmaking your first film is a
narrative mm-hmm or did it sort of not
really there wasn't a decision do an
interest sparked for some so my thinking
behind it was so I did a second
narrative called eavesdrop and then that
had a very hard time getting out there
too so I was very discouraged because I
was trying to figure out well how am I
going to tell the stories I want to tell
and then you have this huge mountain to
climb with raising money and the cast
and you have a very small amount of time
to get it right with a feature to design
like a four or five week onset
experience and there's such long days
and I really was discouraged with the
process of storytelling and the feature
narrative however from those two
directing gig because I got noticed for
some writing because I had written the
scripts so I came out here and I was
doing some writing and I got a manager
and I was working with an agency and I
started working with a couple of
high-profile directors on different
scripts and I was helping to do a couple
of things but ultimately I got
discouraged because with that you
sometimes they're in turnaround a lot of
things you don't get credited if you
work on something and you know you're in
that development thing and sometimes
your work doesn't really pay off because
you can be working on something for so
long it never gets made so then I had
this frustration point where I was like
I just want to tell my stories like how
can I do this a lot easier in a sense
and I'm a New Yorker in my heart and I
as a child used to come into the city
and see the windows at Bergdorf Goodman
and a variety of different storefronts
and I remembered that as a kid and I
used to look up at these windows and say
wow that's like my first approach and
first encounter was storytelling and
like a three-act structure you could see
within just one window and I just absorb
that and then I said to myself you know
what I'd love to do a film on Bergdorf's
because that was my first encounter with
this window or windows I approached them
and they said we don't allow filming and
to do a whole feature would be crazy
because you'd have to buy the store out
and film and it's Multi multi millions
to even think about it
but then I said well let me look at your
archive let me do a little more research
on the place and when they showed me
their archive it was so thin and I was
like well you know you don't keep a
formal archive like you know I'm
surprised it's not huge is a hundred
years old and they said no I said well
let's do a project together let's you
know I'll be I'll be your archive
with interviews and you know we'll
figure it out together and I said let's
do a documentary and they said okay so
for the next two years we were rolling
camera and you know you can greenlight
your project like that without all the
money you need you know to get it done
and also there's this protracted period
where you can work on something for a
longer period of time at your own pace
and you don't have to have that really
concentrated thing and then at that
moment and it was in like 2011 when I
started to think about that and that's
when Doc started to really get hot and
have this golden period which I still
think we're going through and I feel
like storytelling and in a doc forum is
a really refreshing approach if you
really want to get your thing or film
made and out there because you can
literally you know for a thousand two
thousand bucks have a camera start
rolling and greenlight your own project
it's really about picking the right
topic getting the people in it that you
want to interview or a highlight and
just make a compelling story and if you
stitch that all together successfully
you can get something out there in a
theatrical way just as much as a feature
narrative as these days I mean my last
four Doc's all went to theaters so I
feel like and they were rated and it's
like you know you feel like you're doing
it and in it but it was a byproduct and
a result of my frustration with the
feature side so I'm kind of like in the
doc world right now and I've done about
four and I'm about to do two more that
are already shot but I'm entering back
into the feature world now because I got
attached to direct this film on Norman
Rockwell to biopic on that iconic artist
so I'm really excited about that so I'm
kind of like entering back in but I feel
better now because I've accomplished
what I needed to in the doc world and I
feel like with that experience I'll
bring more to my direct
prowess when I get on set and do that
next thing
you